Neutrinos sind
wahre geister teilchen sie sind elektrisch gesehen neutral und haben eine sehr geringe masse fest steht die teilchen haben keinerlei interesse daran
Mit der materie wie wir sie kennen in kontakt
Zu treten doch jetzt hat ein forschungsteam eine überraschende entdeckung gemacht unsere erde
Stockt die neutrinos. Aus den tiefen, des alls und das obwohl. Sie ja eigentlich gar nicht
Zu stoppen sind wie das physik team unsere erde als gigantischen neutrino killer identifiziert hat ob
Er jetzt tatsächlich eine neue physik brauchen und was wir in zukunft mit den neutrinos über die erde erfahren können
Jetzt in kriegs und science und fiction tat sich willkommen
Nicht zu unrecht werden neutrinos als geister teilchen bezeichnet
Ihre masse ist äußerst gering für die erkenntnis dass sie überhaupt eine haben bekamen das entsprechende forschungsteam
2015 den nobelpreis für physik
Die geister teilchen gehen nur wirklich selten eine wechselwirkung mit der materie wie wir sie kennen ein weil sie eben nicht
interagieren rasen sie ungestört durchs all doch jetzt steht fest
neutrinos können materie nicht einfach so ungehindert passieren das haben jetzt
Erstmalig messungen des sogenannten ice cubes gezeigt dass unsere thorium namens. Ice cube das zur amerikanischen amundsen scott
Forschungsstation, am südpol wird ist wohl eines der spannendsten experimente weltweit
5160 sensoren wurden dafür tief in den antarktischen untergrund versenkt und zwar bis zu 2,5 kilometer tief zusammen bilden sie ein riesiges dreidimensionales
würfelförmiges detector fällt echt wahnsinn hier soll die sogenannte
cherenkov strahlung erforscht werden damit ist das leuchten gemeint dass durch die kollision von neutrinos mit den wassermolekülen
des eises
entstehen das passiert nicht oft schätzungsweise ein paar tausend, mal
Im jahr doch wenn es passiert dann richtig pro sekunde prallen zwischen 68 und 100 milliarden euro - auf jeden quadratzentimeter
Der erde ein sie stammen aus der sonne oder etwa gigantischen ereignis. Im weltall wie
supernova explosionen oder
gammastrahlen ausbrüchen und ihre unfassbare beschleunigung kann man sich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen in der aktuellen untersuchung wurden tatsächlich
neutrinos mit einer energie achtung von
980 tera elektronenvolt
analysiert zum vergleich im lhc des genfer kernforschungszentrum cern also dem large hadron collider
Sind protonen mit energien von 13 tera elektronenvolt, am start und noch eine ziemlich krasse rand sind es mittlerweile wurden mit hilfe. Des ice cubes
Auch schon teilchen im bereich von peter. Elektronenvolt gemessen also mehr als 1000 tera elektronenvolt
Das forschungsteam hat jetzt daten aus dem zeitraum von mai 2010 bis mai 2011 ausgewertet insgesamt haben sie
11.000 kollisionen
Im eis analysiert die entsprechenden neutrinos waren mit den wassermolekülen am südpol in der umgebung ice cube
kollidiert zunächst analysierte das forschungsteam den
ursprung der hoch energetischen neutrinos die den detektor erreicht hatten das ergebnis
Ist eine sensation denn die wenigsten?
Teilchen kamen aus der richtung aus der die neutrinos vorab die komplette erde durchqueren mussten hier wurden offensichtlich viele von ihnen
auf ihrem weg abgebremst dazu einer der forscher davon
unsere resultate zeigen zum ersten mal dass neutrinos mit sehr hoher energie von etwas
absorbiert werden können in diesem fall von der erde das ist etwas das bisher noch nie experimentell
nachgewiesen werden konnte überrascht hat aber auch noch eine weitere erkenntnis vor allem die sehr schnelle neutrinos crashten mit den wassermolekülen
überraschend weil das bisher nur für diejenigen geister teilchen experimentell nachgewiesen werden konnte die eher
langsamer unterwegs waren der grund die leistung der
teilchenbeschleuniger reicht nur für niedrige energien aus dennoch der zusammenhang schnelle neutrinos dann große wahrscheinlichkeit für kollision
entspricht voll und ganz dem standardmodell der teilchenphysik
Demnach nimmt die zahl der neutrino kollision mit atomen zu je höher die energie ist dazu francis herzen der chef des ice cube
Experiments wir hatten natürlich gehofft dass wir eine art neuer für sich sähen würden aber wir haben
unglücklicherweise sehen dass das standardmodell die üblich den test besteht ja viele physiker und physikerinnen
Hatten sich wohl hinweise auf exotische teilchen oder extra dimensionen gewünscht es ist schon frappierend. Im moment scheint die forschung dann wirklich
festzustecken ob hier, im ice cube oder am large hadron collider
Dem lhc in genf es wird nichts neues gefunden und das standardmodell der teilchenphysik
Wird immer nur bestätigt doch trotzdem sind diese ergebnisse sehr interessant in zukunft wäre es denkbar dass neutrinos
informationen über das erdinnere liefern beispielsweise
Über die wärme des vulkanismus oder den zerfall von uran
Ja und wenn er kein video zu diesen themen und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drücken wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken herkunft der geister teilchen
enträtselt auch sehr sehr spannend ansonsten bis dann
bleib dran